hey everyone it's Michael Volos from
orderflows dcom here and this is the
orderflows market analysis for Thursday
June 8
2017 and what an interesting day with
the James Comey testimony I mean you
couldn't you can't make this stuff up I
mean as far as TV or movie script and
you also had the UK general election and
you also had ECB rate announcement ECB
rate
announcement came out as expected
nothing happened and we're still waiting
for the election results coming in but
um you know right now Britain is kind of
in uncertainty I think he going to end
up with a hung Parliament and the pound
is diving so anyway uh let's jump into
it before I get started brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
should not be considered solicitation to
buy or sell a Futures Contract or make
any other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than an initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing On's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results
so you know that said it's uh know the
life of a Trader is is a difficult life
at times um you know there's no
guaranteed income you know for example
today you know I had a big argument with
my wife um you know over money you know
she's why why don't you go back to uh
you know a regular job where you got a
stable income rather than doing what I'm
doing where you know you're trading you
know it's it's not stable in the sense
that you know every 15th or 30th of the
month you get paid you know um I'm a big
believer you know money comes money goes
money comes back you know it all goes
around and I said you know with trading
you know trading is you know being a
Trader is like having your own business
and you it has to be run that way if you
want to be successful at it now again
you know nobody can guarantee that you
know your next trade is going to be
profitable you know it it could be a a
losing trade and you know there are
times that I lose right and you know my
my wife sometimes she doesn't understand
that you know she thinks you know every
trade is going to be a big winner that
you know go out and buy her a new BMW or
a Mercedes and you know it's it's not
like that I I tell her you know trading
is is in a sense a job I mean it's it's
it's not I'll say a full-time job in the
sense where you know you you punch in at
9: you leave at 5: but rather you know
it's when you're there
you're focused on the market you know
you can't have distractions you know in
the sense that oh hey let me ask you you
know what color do you like for the
curtains you know red or blue you know
things like that um you know when I'm
trading I tell her I said you know this
is my time okay you know when I'm not in
the office and the door is not closed
okay then we can talk you know and you
can ask me questions about whatever you
know the car this or that you know talk
about the kids things like that but you
know when you know when you're Trading
said you know that's the time that's my
time that's my time that I'm working um
you know for some reason you know some
people you know they they don't respect
it you know so it's important to have a
partner that respects what you do you
know um you know I mean I met my wife
when I was working at JP Morgan you know
and he considered a high flyer there and
you know it was consistent you know you
can spend money like water and you know
now that you're trading for yourself I'm
trading for myself it's it's a little
bit different you know said I I keep
reminding her I said you know got to be
a little bit Frugal because you know I
don't have this um you know guaranteed
salary coming in I don't have a bonus
that's going to come in you know
hopefully come in but you know the big
thing is I don't have that guaranteed
salary that no matter what win or lose
I'm still going to I don't have to worry
about you know the car payment the house
payment the kids school I don't have to
worry about that when I'm working at JP
all that's you know that's all taken
care of you know that stress is a little
bit behind me but you know when you're
Trading for yourself you do have that
stress and you know I mean it doesn't
really get to me that much it only gets
to me when my wife nags at me about it I
hate to use the term nag but sometimes
that's what it feels like but anyway you
know I'm going off on a rant you know
basically what I'm trying to say you
know treat trading as a job or more
importantly treat your trading as a
business you know and and run it that
way I mean you know you're not going to
run a business and just you know spend
money willy-nilly anyhow no you're going
to be very you know you're going to be
checking your every single penny that
comes in right you're going to be you
accounting for every single thing so
again you know when I'm working at bank
I got a lot of money coming in you know
in in the form of of regular pay that
yeah sure you know whatever you know you
want to spend $200 on a shirt go ahead I
don't care now it's was like why you got
to spend $200 on a shirt you know you
get the same shirt for $30 you know
what's the difference um you know I mean
Life's a little bit different when
you're trading for yourself and you know
your your
future you know your future lifestyle
depends on on how well you're Trading
so again um there's nothing wrong with
being Frugal uh you know I'm extravagant
I'm Frugal at the same time you know go
figure but um you know treat your
trading as a business and you know and
hopefully the people that you know your
partners in life whether it's your wife
your girlfriend your boyfriend your
husband um you know explain it to them
so that they understand right and
they're not giving you extra extra
pressure in training you know because
again you know training is is stressful
enough you don't need outside influences
that are going to bring you down so
anyway that said my little rant for the
day tools I use in this presentation the
orderflows trader um volume footprint
chart which is you know my my my chart
that I use and the Delta scalper which
you know is a tool that reads the Delta
for
Traders so let's Jump Right In okay so
First Market I'll talk about is e minis
now today is uh the role Thursday while
it starts so Friday you should I think
you should be looking at the uh
September September S&P contract but um
you know that said you know I'm still
looking at June uh on Thursday so you
you hit your high here 617 you got the
uh Delta scalper giv a sell you get a
little bit of a sell off now at this
point uh coming into 8:00 he had a very
tight range uh 6 36 and 3/4 high 30 and
a half low so we're only talking uh you
know basically fivepoint range
and you know I did think the market was
going to move although you know you did
have the ECB came out did nothing as
expected um the British election is not
going to happen you know results AR
going to be coming out until after the
markets close anyway um and the James
Comey testimony which depending on who
you ask you know everyone's you know
personally me I think he's just full of
a bunch of crap
and you know who who isn't going to be
angry at their boss that uh that um you
lost your job you know I just find it
very strange whole circumstances you
know again people that know me know I'm
a big Trump supporter and uh you know I
just find it ironic you know these
Democrats they say uh you know one day
they don't like Comey the next day he
he's anti-trump and he's great and you
know back and forth you know just a lot
of flip-flopping but anyway you like I
said it's just great great television
you can't make this stuff up great drama
it's just unfortunate that we got to
live with it it's part of our our daily
lives so anyway you know I wasn't sure
how that was going to affect the market
and if anything I expected the market to
kind of quiet down during you know the
early parts of his testimony and it kind
of did um you I said you know early 7
6:30 it did have the Delta scoper given
a sell it went a little bit lower hit
the opening price came back up Delta
scalper almost around the same level
this is 342 to 35 earlier it was 35 1
half to
36 so this is 847 nice Delta scalper
signal trade right down into lows new
lows look at all these selling and
balance is three here three in this bar
boom boom every bar had sell IM balance
you hit this low down here now I
remember in the room I was looking at
this and I was help I I'm a bit hesitant
um you know on this Buy on this Delta
scalper buy for the sole reason that you
know it's already 855
testimony
is is um you know people are going to be
watching it you know they're not going
to be paying attention tomorrow you know
I know I'll be honest I confess in the
room I had one eye on on I was watching
the live stream on YouTube and you know
one eye on the market you know so I do
think people were a little preoccupied
just watching to see what was going on
with the circus and you know we did sort
of slow down um you know we did rally
though um and started hanging around
your opening price for for quite a while
here um another Delta scalper buy but
again you know we're just sort of
hanging around here for the next 20
minutes um we do come down make new lows
sort of rally back up again um at this
low you have a ratio with Divergence I
told you yesterday
and in uh order flow if you just pick
one thing pick ratio with Divergence and
you know it's going to treat you very
well and you had a nice rally here okay
it it just went you know straight up
straight up straight up I say straight
up you know go up go sideways go up go
sideways all the way up into new highs
um you know later up here you don't have
you have a Divergence very it's
borderline ratio um I use 7 this is 768
so it's like a past a ratio um again you
know you can take it if you want but um
you know ratios are not lines in the
Sands they are guidelines okay if you're
watching it
768 is very close to
7 so again if you took it great if you
didn't okay that's fine you get other
opportunities and what happens this
Market goes up to 39 and we sell all the
way back down to um you know down you
know below the opening price get all the
way down to uh 30 and you did go lower
though but um you know I mean is a nice
trade from you know from you know going
back here where you have your first one
your ratio with the Divergence you rally
up to your high you get a borderline
ratio whether or not you take this you
already had a nice um 10-point move
basically eight-point move and now
you're coming back down again another
10-point move I mean you know that's
just two two trades right there you know
makes your day
um later you know again we just sort of
went sideways you know it's kind of a
slow grind there towards the end of the
day okay next up uh 5 years 5 years and
and Bonds were kind of quiet most of the
morning um we did have this nice selloff
though um just after 8 and know 826 you
get up to within a few ticks of your
high you you got ratio ratio ratio some
nice um imbalances here 1300 2,000 3,000
4,000 you got ratios all the way down
here um you know nothing really
actionable there you hit this low you
have a Divergence um then you got you
know three imbalances they're not
stacked but still it's three in a bar
which is you know relatively you know
something to keep an eye out for that
maybe the Market's got some buying
coming in it's bit scattered and then
you know Comey testimony came out and we
just went sideways this is 9116 all the
way up until um basically uh you know
115 then we got a little bit of a pop
higher um you know in the evening
session though we did trade higher
I think that's more as the election
results uh started coming in but for the
most part during the day it was it was
pretty flat um you know then again just
really quick ratio with Divergence on
this high in the evening session and you
have a nice uh you had a nice sell off
there uh really quick the
bonds Hey where's my bond chart give me
a sec here it is
um you know again you know bonds also
you know very similar in the sense that
kind of a quiet morning um we did have
the high here had a a ratio with a
Divergence right here on the low at 723
did rally up from your low to your high
again where you got a ratio of uh
25.75 it's not a ratio I like I used to
actually use 25 I've widened it out a
few years ago to 30 with the Divergence
did come back make a new high here by a
couple of ticks and then made the sell
off that you know same sell off that you
saw in the uh in the 5 years um not
really much to alert you on this selloff
unfortunately in the order
flow um you come down here you got point
of control near the bottom You' got a uh
ratio with a Divergence so you got
Divergence followed up in the no ratio
that you like but the next bar you had a
ratio so you got ratio and Divergence in
the next bar and unfortunately it just
went sideways on you I mean it did you
know poke a little bit higher but I mean
again you know you're getting along
somewhere around you know 04 at
924 and you know an hour later it's
still trading around 04 it's you know I
would have thrown in the towel um we did
get a little bit higher here Delta
scalare gave a sell but again you know
we're just sort of going sideways at
this point I we did go lower a little
bit you know not much um in the night
session though we did uh we did drift
higher um you know we had that high just
before 8:00 Chicago time with a ratio
but no
Divergence um next Market we'll look at
is the uh Bridge pump pound oh sorry
eurocurrency and eurocurrency it's going
to be kind of difficult because you do
have you know the ECB rate announcement
so you know you're going to get a lot of
uh volatility you know 645 then
obviously the press conference
afterwards that's why you see um not
much you know it's just all ones and
zeros in there because there's no
liquidity at that time when the rate
announcement comes out but um you know
just going
back earlier in the morning
um you know just be careful with you
know trading divergences by themselves
because you see you got Divergence that
fails Divergence another few divergences
that fail you know on trending days
you're going to get failed divergences
and if you're just buying every single
failed every Divergence on the way down
you're going to get your head handed to
okay so anyway um you what I want to
talk about is 6:45 is the announcement
then obviously you have the press
conference that comes out
later um I mean there are signals in
there but again it's going to be
difficult trading that because by the
time you know you say hey I I want to
buy this here time you get filled you
know you're already 10 ticks away from
you know your entry price but um those
was what was it
here you know things pretty much slowed
down after
8:00 so let's take a look at
8ish I think there was something I
wanted to talk about so okay so me
things are are kind of quieting down a
little bit you know here you got the
Delta SC give it a sell swing High here
um you hit 25 first time you hit it the
high second time three I like when you
get less volume the second time around
and you sell off you know quite nicely
you do rally up a little
bit you know you go from the uh 30 Area
31 area down into the 15 area before you
bounce up um a bit here um and you go
back down now again you got this Delta
scalper giv a buy here but it's red
candle um not interested in it here you
got Delta scalper given a buy did it
work no it failed I mean it didn't go up
initially but then it failed it came
right back down came right back down you
got a bunch of selling stack selling
imbalances one right after the other
here here you have a stack buying
imbalance but again you know if you have
a stack buying imbalance and you get a
stack s balance within the Zone it's
very bearish because you have you know
I've explained it before I'm not going
to say why but here basically you know
when you get a stacked imbalance within
the next few bars you get a stacked
imbalance going the other direction go
in the other direction and you you get a
nice move move down right towards your
low um get within a tick of your low
before you rally back
up um you know then you get this Delta
scalper given a sell here you know this
is right around the 26 area where we
sell off down to the uh 18 area you know
Delta scalper buy that one didn't work
um then here you got a nice Delta
scalper buy um you get the swing low
right here you got a
ratio you had this Delta scalper Buy
around the you know it's kicking in
you'd be getting in somewhere in the
next bar around 15
14 and what happens the market just
starts taking off this is uh you know it
happens about 12:39 you know an hour I
say an hour but um yeah about an hour
later you know you're
trading um you know in the
30s so you know that was a nice trade
and and overnight right now we at this
point um you know we are we are coming
off here so anyway that was the um euro
currency and uh I'll take a look at
crude really quick I can't remember if
there's anything I I know there's some
interesting stuff but let me just see if
I could find it really quick here where
am I here crude oil
so again um you got
a Delta scalper giving you a buy here
this one didn't work out it started
going up came right back down then here
you got um Delta scalper giv another Buy
and you get a little pop up Delta
scalper then gives a sell signal and it
goes lower lower lower lower into new
lows and again this is sort of what I've
talking about the day before right you
have a trade it it's a losing trade then
if you're kicking yourself thinking oh
you know I'm going to wait then you miss
the next trade that's the winner and
then maybe you know or maybe you break
even on this trade and you think ah you
know I'm not going to take the next
trade and you miss this trade you know
you miss getting short here at 52 and
next thing you know it sells off to to
new lows you know in the mid 20s and
you're kicking yourself oh why didn't I
take it uh you know and trading sucks
but I mean it's about sticking with um
you know your your your your analysis
here you got a ratio with the Divergence
um we came down made a new low by two
ticks before you popped up and just went
you know went higher um you know does it
suck that you know you had a ratio with
Divergence and came down stopped you out
maybe you know if you have your stop
right below this bar and stopped you out
you know maybe you're you're a little
bit wider on your stop who knows
but yeah it it suckss you me the market
hasn't quite found its low unfortunately
it does find its low two tick lower
before putting in the big Rally from um
you know the 30 area all the way up to
the oh you know where' it get all the
way up into the 70s 80s even higher
um here's Delta scoper giving a cell I'm
not interested in it because it's a
green bar if it's a cell I want to see a
red
bar and you know up here at the swing
High you got a nice Delta scalper cell
follow by the Delta surge here and but
really you know this this is the bar to
to take the trade off of so you know you
should be getting short around the you
know 45 96 97 area
and you know it trades all the way down
to the
60s before working its way back up so
there there's some interesting things in
the crude again Delta scalp are giving a
sell here um again depending on where
your stop is did you get stopped out
here who knows um you know but then it
finally made its move you know here you
got Delta scalper Buy see that here um
just sort of went sideways on you um to
the
close okay I'll look at Japanese n
really
quick uh where am I here
okay I want to go back
here
okay um
where was it that I wanted to talk about
so again Delta scalper buy but it's on a
red bar I'm not interested on it um you
come down into these lows you got a
ratio with the Divergence starts going
off but then it turns around you got a
stack buying imbalance it's Follow by a
stack selling imbalance almost you know
two bars later go with this and you know
it's 9:00 where things are starting to
happen we do sell off a bit lower um you
come down here you've got a Divergence
no ratio that you like unfortunately
comes up here you got this double top
you know up here you got a ratio on the
second bar and you know point of control
near the top which you know by this bar
by itself I'd find this bearish um
doesn't sell off not really just goes
sideways then you come up in here you
got a few bearish signs you got Delta
scalper stack selling imbalance Delta
scalper um you know Delta scalper again
but the Market's not going anywhere it's
at that time where you know it's Z 10:00
is basically around the European close
time um you don't necessarily get a lot
of movement you get a lot of sideways
action um at this point I was waiting to
see you know is this Market going to go
sideways or or what um I really wasn't
seeing much happening in the orderflow
to really give me direction one way or
the
other um you know and you just didn't
really get it Asia did it did uh did
have some nice movements during Asia you
know Japanese and Aussie dollar are
markets you can you can trade during the
Asian market with uh generally decent
liquid I mean the problem is the Aussie
dollar doesn't necessarily move that
much um it's got very good liquidity but
you know sometimes you you just don't
get movements this is the Aussie dollar
here um he's got nice liquidity you can
see during Asia but you know the
movements aren't that great I mean
sometimes there they are I mean
obviously there's Aussie data that comes
out but um you know in general
it's you know it's it's not necessarily
a market that as volatile as say the
euro currency or um
or the
japen so anyway you know I'm not uh [__]
it I'll just talk about British pound
really quick if I can find it
[Music]
um why not uh again you know you have
the UK general
election
and I'm not going to talk about the
night session right now just go back to
the day
session where are we
here let's go back a bit here
so again you know you got you know ratio
with Divergence you got Delta scaler
here doesn't work out make new Low by
two ticks and you got ratio with
Divergence and it just goes sideways on
you unfortunately again you know people
always ask you know how do how do you
know when to get out well I'll be honest
with you you get into a trade the next
bar is next three bars is you know the
same price levels going sideways get out
you know wait for a market that's going
to move you know you're looking for
something to happen and it's not
happening so you know over time the
trade reason for being in the trade
loses its Effectiveness don't stay in a
trade thinking it's going to go
eventually I said it should happen if it
doesn't happen get out um then you get
these lows here this is 7 just before
8:00 you know ratio ratio no divergences
um you know then you get divergences as
you made new
lows again you know I have this o2x
trade you know you got a low with a
ratio try and buy it you know within two
ticks off the low you know might not
have gotten it here but you could have
gotten it here for a little bit of a pop
higher then um you know a bit later you
get the swing High nice one um with the
Delta scalper negative Delta single
print right up there and you know it's a
nice move from uh
12950 you know all the way down to uh
you know down to the 30s where you got a
Delta scalper giving you another buy
here and it sort of works its way back
up and then obviously later um this is
already late in the day about 3 :00
Chicago time um beans I'll talk about
Beans really quick cuz there was
something that was developing you know I
I had bigger expectations out of it
didn't necessarily happen unfortunately
but uh where was it here so
8:30 they reopen and start making new
highs here not you know ratio with
Divergence a little bit of a selloff
about two cents if that got a bunch of
ratios sorry divergences that failed
here here here then you got Delta
scalper right here off the high again I
was very encouraged by this I thought
you know maybe we can make a move this
bar came right back up but then here you
got a ratio um ratio bounds low
indicating some stopping volume at this
point I was looking for this Market to
sell off down into you know 937 936 it
doesn't it just comes right back up and
makes new highs you know so my analysis
on that was was wrong um I was expecting
the market to rally and it didn't or
sorry expecting the market to sell off
and it rallied instead got up here to
this new high yeah again there's not
much in there I like this I think there
was some trap Traders up this area in
here around the 943 and A2 area and it
was a nice sell off um I I like this bar
here with the imbal buying and balance
there then you got the single print
coming right back up to that area so you
know we got heavy volume there we
testing that area back here you got a
single print so I know there's um price
rejection and then the market puts a
nice uh little move lower down to this
937 area but honestly I I was expecting
this this move
here that happened here I expected that
to happen right after this Delta scalper
it didn't it still had a new high to
make before it made that but again there
were some signs in here that you know
you could be looking to get short you
don't have a stack selling imbalance
here but you got three imbalances in the
bar again you know just because they're
not stacked on top of each other doesn't
mean it's not it's not effective um you
know that's one of the beauties of order
flows you could see that right I mean
you know if I wanted to I could have my
programmer say Hey you know if over a
certain percentage of the bar is
imbalances you know draw Draw Something
there but you don't need to I mean you
use your eyes you know you could process
that um that's important to note you
know you got you're right off out your
high and you got aggressive selling
coming in with three imbalances in a bar
that has five price levels so over half
the bar is aggressive selling and the
market moves lower you know I mean that
that that's not brain surgery you know
that's just common sense market analysis
of
orderflow so anyway guys um you know
thanks for watching this video and you
know if you're interested in learning
more about orderflow visit my website
orderflows